almost a billion euros of parliament's
target and the first reduction in
history but finally europe has a 135.5
billion euro budget for 2014 after a
deal was struck on tuesday
and it's also good news for parliament
who've ensured that member states have
to honor their fund pledges
to make a comparison
in this
financial framework from 2007 until now
there is a lost about
60 billion euro now we are not going to
lose that that money this is the
instrument which is going to make the
use much more efficient not only could
this be a more cost-effective budget
it's also astute not only does it ensure
that all outstanding bills are cleared
front loading of key programs such as r
d and the youth guarantee scheme means
the programmes that encourage growth and
jobs will be given the money they need
from the outset and if we run out of
money well meps have also secured a
midterm review in 2016.
i think that in two years time we are
going to have a better idea how the
european economy is developing and
eventually to
increase additionally or to to reshuffle
the spending but not all were happy with
the budget
certainly with a lower budget
maintaining
the level of structural funds and
agriculture
is a very conservative policy there is
need for more reforms and reform may
well come meps have negotiated for a
working group to be set up that could
one day see control over the budget
wrestled away from member states a more
democratic europe it's essential that
the parliament decides on income and
expenses where at the european level
we have little or nothing to say at the
level of the of the resources and and
that's
indeed not a very democratic and
responsible position for the european
parliament all aboard the strasbourg
plenary where meps will give their final
blessing to the 2014 and seven year
budget